black panther first appeared in 1966's  Fantastic Four number 52 in the issue he  sends an emissary to New York City with  the gift of a high-tech flying vehicle  and an invitation to the FF to come to  wakanda as his guests upon their arrival  to Chala and his subjects surprised the  Fantastic Four by attacking them it's a  test black panther hopes to get the ff's  help in dealing with the villain Ulysses  S claw but first wants to make sure  they're up to it the FF work as a team  and overcome black panther but  individually t'challa is more than a  match for any single member of the team  he traps the Human Torch and sniffs out  the invisible Susan storm against the  PowerHouse thing Panther is able to hold  his own with nothing but his fists and  wits since then the Fantastic Four and  black panther have maintained close ties  t'challa even temporarily took over as  leader of the team after the events of  Civil War